heute live an diesem dienstagabend genau
eine woche bevor die frist ausläuft in
afghanistan bis dahin ihr wisst es
wahrscheinlich bis zum 31 august sollten
die westlichen bündnispartner eigentlich
abgezogen sein aber das ist eben die
frage wird dieser termin gehalten gibt
es eine verlängerung danach sieht es im
moment nicht aus kanzlerin merkel war
heute dabei beim virtuellen g7-gipfel
und sie spricht im moment in berlin wir
haben mal rein haben das unter sehr
schwierigen bedingungen die ja für alle
gelten ist eine reibungslose kooperation
untereinander gibt unter führung der
amerikanischen armee und der
us-streitkräfte und da sind wir schon
sehr dankbar über die professionalität
mit der da gearbeitet wird aber ich
denke auch unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten leisten da ein sehr
herausragenden job
vorrang hat für uns die evakuierung
deutscher staatsbürger die
zahlen ändern sich auch immer wieder wir
haben einen großen teil der
außenminister hat das ja heute auch
schon gesagt bereits evakuiert wir
kennen von denen uns bekannten namen
auch die aufenthaltsorte und es wird mit
hochdruck daran gearbeitet auch diese
menschen außer landes zu bringen
frau merkel einen tag wie diesen kommt
man auch einem anderen thema nicht von
nicht vorbei ihre partei stehe den
umfragen zum ersten mal seit über 15
jahren wieder hinter hinter der spd ist
auf dem historischen tiefpunkt wie groß
ist die eigene anteil und vielleicht
auch der anteil der aktuell
afghanistan-politik in diesem desaster
also wir
kämpfen oder die partei kämpft ich stehe
selbst nicht zur wahl
und wir haben eine gute eröffnung des
der heißen phase des wahlkampfs gehabt
und wir würden uns jeden tag dafür
einsetzen dass wir ein gutes
wahlergebnis einfahren und nicht jeden
tag auf die umfragen schauen zum schluss
zählen die stimmen der bürgerinnen und
bürger in der wall box und die probleme
die sich ergeben dass ist die pandemie
das ist jetzt dieses sehr sehr bittere
thema afghanistan die werden von der
regierung so
bearbeitet und so gestaltet dass es
möglichst gut für die menschen in
unserem land ist
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben gesagt es
wurden keine neuen daten genannt ob die
evakuierungs mission verlängert werden
kann liegt dass er daran dass das
niemand wollte im g7 kreis oder dass die
taliban gesagt haben zum 31 august ist
schluss und wie groß würden sie in
diesem zusammenhang überhaupt noch den
einfluss des westens bewerten hat er da
in irgendeiner weise noch das heft des
handelns in der hand oder es eher den
taliban ausgeliefert die realität ist
dass die taliban in weiten teilen des
landes die kontrolle übernommen haben
und dass die taliban auch ja öffentlich
deutlich gemacht haben welche wie sie es
genannt haben rote linie es gibt und die
frage dass wir so lange wie möglich
menschen evakuieren wollen ist klar aber
dass wir da auch auf die sicherheits
gegebenheiten schauen müssen die sich
eben auch sehr schwierig gestalten und
darauf hat der amerikanische präsident
normal hingewiesen und dem hat auch
niemand widersprochen das muss natürlich
mit ins kalkül gezogen werden wir können
nur operationen vertreten bei denen die
sicherheit auch nach menschlichem
ermessen gewährleistet ist also die
vorstellungen der taliban spielen
natürlich eine rolle weil sie kabul
kontrollieren und zweitens spielen die
sicherheitsbedingungen eine rolle denn
wir wollen und dürfen unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten keine unangemessenen risiko
aussetzen das gilt für alle und auch
nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger die wir
evakuieren wollen
ok danke schön
[Musik]
soweit also ein erstes statement der
bundeskanzlerin wir werden versuchen
wichtige aussagen ihrer rede nachher
nochmal nachzutragen sprechen jetzt aber
mit thomas wiegold er ist experte für
außen und sicherheitspolitik auch
journalist und hat einen eigenen blog
augen geradeaus heißt dieser berichtet
seit 1993 über einsätze der bundeswehr
bevor er zum statement der
bundeskanzlerin kommen herr wie gold
vielleicht noch mal gerade die frage wie
schätzen sie denn die aktuelle lage in
kabul ein und erreichen jeden tag
dramatische szenen wie beobachten sie
das
also nach allem was ich sehe spitzte
sich
täglich auf jeden fall fast schon
stündlich weiter zu und ich fürchte nach
dem was wir jetzt von der kanzlerin und
dann auch vom us präsidenten gehört
haben dass es jetzt nämlich ein ende der
evakuierungsflüge geben wird wird das
noch mal schlimmer werden das wird
voraussichtlich mehr verzweifelte
menschen geben die zum flughafen zu
strömen versuchen und die hoffnung haben
auch wenn das unrealistisch ist
irgendwie auf einen flug ausser landes
zu kommen sie haben schon darauf
hingewiesen dass sind in der tat die
ersten agenturmeldungen die uns zu
diesem thema erreichen dass also
präsident biden der us präsident gesagt
hat es wird keine verlängerung ergeben
und ohne die usa da braucht man kein
prophet sein wird es auch für die
partner nicht möglich sein ihren einsatz
zu verlängern was bedeutet das nun für
die ortskräfte überhaupt für die
menschen vor ort
nun das bedeutet dass ein sehr großer
teil von ihnen nicht rauskommen wird wir
haben ja schon die meldung der
vergangenen tage dass selbst die abgaben
die ortskräfte die ein visum haben die
eine aufnahme zusage deutscher tagen es
nicht zwingend an bord der maschinen
schaffen und es gibt tausende vermutlich
so die geben mit den genauen zahlen sind
etwas schwierig im moment es gibt
tausende nicht nur der bundeswehr
sondern auch anderer
bundesinstitutionen
regierungsinstitutionen deutscher
institutionen die es jetzt nicht
schaffen werden rauszukommen das heißt
sie sehen auch keine chance weil davon
ist auch in den agenturen die rede dass
also versucht werden soll über das datum
hinaus die ausreise irgendwie zu
ermöglichen ohne dann noch eigene
präsenz vor ort also sie sehen auch
wenig chancen dafür dass das klappen
könnte
das würde eine solle das wird eines
völlig neuen anlaufs bedürfen das
problem ist dass der zivile flughafen
derzeit nicht funktionsfähig ist da sind
die ganzen einrichtungen teilweise
zerstört der flughafen derzeit
funktioniert nur weil die usa einen
militärischen flughafen mit eigener
infrastruktur sozusagen
aufgezogen haben für die
luftverkehrskontrolle für die
vorfeldkontrolle für das beladen und
entladen wenn diese ganzen militärischen
einrichtungen weg sind dann gibt es erst
einmal keinen funktionsfähigen flughafen
deswegen gibt es natürlich auch
gespräche das hat die kanzlerin gerade
auch noch mal gesagt zu versuchen
irgendwie diesen flughafen wieder in
betrieb zu nehmen dann mit zivilen
mitteln mit zivilen firmen aber das wird
sicherlich eine weile dauern also es
gibt erst einmal wenn diese militärische
luftbrücke vorbei ist gibt es erst
einmal bis auf weiteres keine
flugmöglichkeiten vielen dank thomas
wiegold bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich
weiter wollen jetzt aber doch noch mal
hören was die bundeskanzlerin noch
sozusagen hatte in ihrem statement nach
dem virtuellen g7 sondergipfel es wird
jetzt eine
gruppe eingesetzt werden von den g7 die
sich darum bemühen wird eine einen
fahrplan sozusagen zu entwickeln wie wir
auch die
verabredung mit den taliban in zukunft
gestalten können wir wollen hier
einheitlich auftreten gemeinsam
auftreten als g 7 denn es nützt nichts
wenn jeder seine eigene
anstrengungen macht aber man kann sagen
die
evakuierungsaktion erfolgt in großer
gemeinsamkeit natürlich das will ich
noch einmal betonen haben die
vereinigten staaten von amerika hier die
führung ohne die vereinigten staaten von
amerika können wir zum beispiel die
anderen die
evakuierungsaktion nicht weiterführen
das muss man ganz klar wissen und so wie
wir diese evakuierungsaktion jetzt
einheitlich gestalten wollen wir auch
das weitere vorgehen im umgang mit
afghanistan weiter einheitlich gestalten
also ein einheitlicher umgang wird zu
angemahnt das ist ja auch das was der
britische premier boris johnson immer
gefordert hat wie sehen sie da die
chancen wird die eu ist schaffen damit
zu einer stimme zu sprechen
also es wird jetzt ja nicht um
militärische aktionen gehen insofern
kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass sich
die eu und sicherlich auch die
europäischen nato-länder da leichter tun
als wenn es darum geht militärisch zu
agieren was das bedeutet wie schnell das
geht also die kanzlerin hat auch gesagt
es wird eine quasi eine arbeitsgruppe
der g7 staaten gehen das klingt alles
nicht danach als ob das jetzt den
nächsten tagen oder auch nur in den
nächsten wochen erfolg haben wird wir
müssen ja sehen nächsten dienstag das
ist heute in einer woche sollen alle
internationalen truppen vom flughafen
kabul abgezogen seien aus den usa kam
bereits die meldung dass das us militär
angekündigt hat dann müssen wir am
freitag mit dem abzug beginnen das
bedeutet wiederum für alle anderen
staaten auch deutschland also auch die
bundeswehr das sie mindestens zeitgleich
wenn nicht er ihren abzug organisieren
muss und das wiederum bedeutet die
evakuierungsflüge werden voraussichtlich
am donnerstag enden so hat das
frankreich heute auch schon angekündigt
also wenn wir jetzt über kurzfristige
dinge reden dann wird es eher schlimmer
werden dann wird sich kurzfristig nichts
tun all diese ankündigungen die g7 die
eu all diese länder die sich engagieren
wollen das ist eher etwas was in der
langfristigen perspektive zu betrachten
ist
ja also das zeitfenster wird in der tat
dann wohl eher noch kürzer werden als
länger vielleicht noch mal die frage an
sie wie schätzen sie denn jetzt die
akute
bedrohungslage die gefährdung für die
menschen vor ort gerade für die
ortskräfte 1
die bedrohung ist hoch und sie scheint
auch weiter zu steigen es gibt ja man
muss sagen noch unbestätigte gerüchte
dass gezielt nach den früheren
mitarbeitern der internationalen truppen
gesucht wird wir müssen dazu sagen alle
informationen die die uns hier in
deutschland erreichen die uns in europa
erreichen kommen ja im wesentlichen aus
kabul wenn überhaupt aus dem land selbst
aus masar i scharif aus kundus gibt es
nur sehr punktuell informationen und
auch daher gibt es immer wieder einzelne
meldungen die sagen ortskräfte frühere
übersetzer zum beispiel werden von den
taliban gezielt gesucht wir sprechen
gleich weiter ich würde gerne noch ein
statement mit reinnehmen von markus
gross jahren er ist hauptmann der
bundeswehr und er ist gründer des
patenschafts netzwerks afghanische
ortskräfte er hat in der vergangenheit
schon sehr eindrücklich die aus seiner
sicht verfehlte und enttäuschende
politik der bundesregierung kritisiert
und er hat das auch heute wieder getan
wir sind überwältigt von
fassungslosigkeit weil
regierungsparteien und politiker die
warnungen missachtet die hinweise und
lösungsmöglichkeiten ignoriert die
verantwortlichkeiten abgeschoben haben
und bis heute die eigenen verfahren und
handlungen loben da sind vorher schon
grundsätzliche probleme entstanden die
jetzt dazu geführt haben dass wir hier
in einem nadelöhr versuchen menschen
durchzuschleusen und da wird es zu
vielen kaputt zu vielen menschlichen
tragödien kommen völlig klar jeder der
für deutsche gearbeitet hat muss jetzt
dort durchgelassen werden weil es nicht
mehr viele chancen geben wird die sind
jetzt drei mal abgewiesen worden
teilweise ein viertes ein fünftes mal
gibt es vielleicht mehr und dann fliegen
vielleicht keine flieger mehr
also da ist wirklich eine große
menschliche tiefe enttäuschung zu spüren
sie begleiten die bundeswehr ich hab's
eingangs gesagt seid auch fast 30 jahren
können sie ja diese haltung die er hat
verstehen
das kann ich durchaus verstehen roth war
ja selber als soldat auch im einsatz und
man hört dass immer wieder von soldaten
die in afghanistan waren die sagen ohne
diese unterstützung dieser ortskräfte
ohne unseren übersetzer hätten wir viele
dinge ja gar nicht machen können denn es
gibt ja kaum einen deutschen soldaten
der dario oder paste spricht also um
überhaupt dinge zu erfahren und da geht
es nicht nur darum small talk mit der
bevölkerung zu machen da ging es ja auch
darum informationen zu gewinnen da ging
es darum die abstimmung mit mit der
afghanischen armee mit den afghanischen
sicherheitskräften zu machen all diese
dinge hat daten übersetzer eine
wesentliche bedeutung und da reden wir
doch nicht über die ganzen anderen
kräfte die gebraucht wurden den betrieb
der feldlager aufrecht zu erhalten also
ohne diese menschen hätte dieser
20-jähriger einsatz nicht funktioniert
deswegen kann ich das durchaus
nachvollziehen aber warum tut sich denn
dann die bundesregierung aus ihrer sicht
so schwer da jetzt ganz pragmatisch und
vielleicht nicht so bürokratisch wie es
ja oft eben auch vorgeworfen wird zu
handeln und eben möglichst und auch
frühzeitig jetzt ist es natürlich sehr
spät ortskräfte auszufliegen
nun jetzt macht sich ein gewisser
pragmatismus breit aber wie sie sagen
das ist im grunde genommen zu spät man
hätte das vor monaten machen müssen und
da galten dann noch andere bedingungen
da galten andere vorschriften
der galt ist zunächst mal waren ja nur
ortskräfte
antragsberechtigt überhaupt den
vergangenen zwei jahren für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet hatten das wurde
dann ausgedehnt auch die jahre bis 2014
20 13 aber zu einem zeitpunkt wo die
meisten kaum noch eine chance hatten
nach kabul zu fahren das war nämlich
auch dann vorgesehen nachdem die
bundeswehr weg war im norden und dort
das verfahren zu machen und das
patenschafts netzwerk ortskräfte das
hellrot jahren organisiert das hatte in
kabul 111 aus eingerichtet wo diese
menschen auf den abschluss ihres
verfahren zu waten konnten so war
zumindest die idee das waren ja auch von
dieser privat organisation charter flüge
geplant das hat sich dann mit dem sehr
raschen einmarsch der taliban in kabul
alles erledigt also offensichtlich sind
in deutsche regierungsinstitutionen viel
zu spät aufgewacht das gilt ja auf
verschiedenen ebenen was die situation
in afghanistan angeht und wenn ich dann
sehe dass das
entwicklungshilfeministerium jetzt am
vergangenen wochenende gesagt hat nun
wir weiten auch den zeitraum aus von
zwei jahren auf die jahre davor während
die evakuierung solche operationen schon
lief dann kann man nur sagen sind aber
spät dran
spät dran in der tat die kritischen
einschätzungen von thomas wiegold außen
und sicherheitspolitik experte
journalist und eben auch begleiter der
bundeswehr vielen dank dass sie sich die
zeit genommen haben heute abend ja und
wir wollen noch mal auf den tag schauen
in afghanistan mein kollege tim kröger
fast diesen noch mal zusammen auch die
situation speziell am flughafen in kabul
wo ja immer noch tausende auf ihre
ausreise warten
die evakuierungsmaßnahmen am flughafen
von kabul laufen auf hochtouren ein
flugzeug nach dem anderen hebt ab mit
staatsbürgern und orts kräften aber
immer noch harren menschen am flughafen
aus die es bislang nicht auf eine der
rettende maschinen geschafft haben wir
haben auch vollständige dokumente aber
alle tore sind geschlossen sie lassen
niemanden rein sondern schicken uns von
einem zum nächsten und so weiter
auch die bundeswehr fliegt seit tagen
menschen aus bislang rund 4000 aber es
gibt massive kritik am vorgehen der
bundesregierung mann habe offenbar
bewusst und wissentlich menschen
zurückgelassen so der leiter des
patenschafts werks für afghanische
ortskräfte
in diesen minuten werden menschen
abgelehnt an den weil sie nicht auf
listen stehen am flughafen in kabul weil
sie zu einer zeit für ein ressort
gearbeitet haben was nicht bürokratisch
erfasst ist alle anderen länder
evakuieren jetzt alle ortskräfte wir
evakuieren die die man ausgewählt hat
das finden wir verwerflich wie viele
ortskräfte überhaupt noch das land
verlassen können wird immer ungewisser
am nachmittag gaben die taliban eine
pressekonferenz
man wolle dass die amerikaner alle
ausländer bis zum 31 august evakuieren
so ein sprecher in kabul
man unterstütze nicht dass weitere
afghanen das land verlassen
zudem scheint sich die
menschenrechtslage zu verschlechtern
laut den un gibt es glaubwürdige
berichte über hinrichtungen und
einschränkungen der rechte von frauen
und wir sammeln weiter reaktionen auf
die entscheidung der g7 die ja so
langsam durchgesickert ist dass es also
keine fristverlängerung geben wird
sprechen darüber mit franz marty es
freier journalist aus der schweiz lebt
und arbeitet seit mehreren jahren in
afghanistan unter anderem tätig für die
deutsche welle und auch für die
tagesschau schön dass sie bei uns sind
herr marty wir haben wie gesagt gerade
gehört es wird keine fristverlängerung
geben wie ist diese nachricht aus ihrer
sicht zu bewerten
das war zu erwarten
es hat schon zu wäre zu hoch solche
anzeichen gegeben also hier ist es zu
sagen die offizielle ankündigung ist
noch nicht da es gab in diesen berichten
auch irgendwie noch dass notfallpläne
sind als man dann doch irgendwie
wenn es keine frist verlängern gibt wird
sicher schwierig alle leute
herauszuholen die man eigentlich
ausholen wollte über diese kooperation
sie sind ja vor ort in kabul wie kriegen
sie das mit wie groß ist auch die angst
der leute davor jetzt doch nicht mehr
rauszukommen repressionen der taliban
ausgesetzt zu sein
die angst unseren leuten die da am
flughafen sehen und versuchen
herauszukommen ist extrem groß die sind
wirklich in panik die glauben dass die
tolle kommen sie umbringen wenn sie
nicht herauskommen etwas was es da zu
beachten gibt ist wir reden von
tausenden von leuten kabul ist eine
millionenstadt millionen bleiben hier
und ob freiwillig oder unfreiwillig
versuchen sich mit den neuen machthabern
zu engagieren es ist sicher dass gewisse
leute
gewissen größeren bedrohungen ausgesetzt
sind
aber bisher gibt es keine anzeichen dass
oliver und systematisch jeden jahren der
doch irgendwie mal mit ausländern
gearbeitet hat bis zum gewissen gerade
ist die drohung glaubhaft und ist die
angst endlich bis zu einem gewissen
grade ist sie aber zumindest in einigen
fällen auch übertrieben also das heißt
sie schätzen die taliban doch so ein
weil das ist ja auch momentan gegenstand
der diskussion dass sie sich durchaus
auch gemäßigt haben könnten
bis zu einem gewissen grade ja ich habe
selber mit armee offiziere gesprochen
mit geheimdienstmitarbeitern gesprochen
die sich ein taliban ergeben haben und
die wohl nicht an die wand gestellt und
erschossen geht es den gut sind die
bedroht das sind natürlich schwierige
fragen abgeben ich sage nicht dass die
taliban die gemäßigt sind und jetzt
nicht jeden behandeln oder dass man den
die generalamnestie völlig abkaufen
sollte
berichte dass die da von haus zu haus
gehen und jeden erschießen das hat man
bisher nicht gesehen es giesst nicht zu
massenexekutionen gekommen und da kommt
das wirklich auf den fall haben ja
einige leute sind einige auf ganz stehen
unter extrem großer bedrohung und deren
leben dies gefährdet wenn sie ihr
bleiben aber an diesen 1000 leuten die
am flughafen sind
jeder übersetzer wird nicht einfach
exekutiert problemen es kommt wirklich
haften einzelfall daran und es ist auch
sehr man kann da nicht generalisieren
naja gut also jeder einzelne der
exekutiert wird der wird das ganze
vielleicht anders sehen als sie aber
außenminister heiko maas hat auch schon
gesagt dass es nicht möglich sein wird
alle die
schutzbedürftig sind auszufliegen also
das hat er eingeräumt dazu wird es nicht
kommen wie ist es für sie persönlich
empfinden sie angst furcht vor den
taliban
bisher nicht ob ich bin auch in anderen
positionen ausländischen ließ die
taliban haben zugesichert dass die
ausländischen diplomaten journalisten
nichts anhaben natürlich kann man einen
taliban dauer nicht hundertprozentig
vertrauen aber es ist in ihrem eigenen
interesse
sicher ausländische journalisten
irgendwie nicht zu behaupten und zu
bringen also neben im schlimmsten fall
werde ich das landes verwiesen aber für
mich gesteht sie sie bedrohen nicht ich
bin da in einer privilegierten position
keine frau gehen und das konnten wir
nicht mit aufbauen vergleichen haben sie
denn vor in afghanistan zu bleiben was
für eine art von gesellschaft von leben
auch für sich selbst erwarten sie jetzt
in den nächsten
wochen monaten
ich habe vor zu bleiben
außerdem meist mich raus bisher haben
die taliban ins öffentliche leben wenig
eingegriffen das wird sich sicher ändern
alle zeichen stehen dafür dass
einschneidende massnahmen erlassen
werden von selber als als morgen wird
sich da weniger verändern oder wenn man
sich dann halt einfach ich soll einen
gewissen grade neuen regeln
denke ich wird sich das arrangieren
lassen aber mit sicherheit kann ich das
nicht sagen ich muss sagen schauen wie
ich mich engagiere in diesem
zusammenhang sei anzumerken dass ich in
den kommenden jahren 120 endliche
taliban gebiete besucht habe und das
ging auch irgendwie neu ich bin in einer
privilegierten position für afghanen die
hier leben ist das natürlich ist das
natürlich anders privilegiert auch nicht
zuletzt weil sie einen mann sind darauf
haben sie gerade selber auch noch einmal
hingewiesen wir nehmen unsere user mal
mit in die sendung so lehmann lüge
schreibt jetzt gibt es unzählige drohnen
und man hat die taliban immer noch nicht
im griff das verstehe ich nicht
vielleicht um das ganze noch mal
aufzuweiten also es ist ja wohl nicht
allein ein militärisches problem gewesen
sondern eben vielleicht auch ein
akzeptanzproblem die loyalität auch der
sicherheitskräfte war vielleicht nicht
so hoch gegenüber dem afghanischen staat
wie sich der westen das vorgestellt hat
oder wie sehen sie das
es gab eine ganze reihe von problemen
aber diese frage wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe war quasi so mithalten
drohnen und alte technologie wieso man
die taliban nicht besiegen konnte das
hört nach hof von afghanen die modernste
armee der welt konnte ziemlich besiegen
die wahrheit ist die wenn sie wenn sie
genügend motivierte leute haben die sich
verstecken können die in der zivilen
bewölkung verschwinden können es ist
praktisch unmöglich eine abstand zu
besiegen einem pony baumann sieht dem
nicht auch opera ein taliban ist er
kleidet sich wie ein normaler aufgabe
sieht aus wie ein normaler und ein
taliban habe mir selber gesagt dass sie
mal dass sie meistens teilzeit kämpfe
aus der vlugt eine stunde sein feld um
den nächsten stunde ist ein
taliban-kämpfer und da hat natürlich vor
allem die ausländischen kräfte die
weniger bitter kultur vertraut sind um
die die weniger ortskenntnisse haben
glaubt ich keine chance den feind
überhaupt zu identifizieren die
afghanische armee
hat es da eben mit dem aufkommen von
scan ist ein bisschen einfacher aber im
endeffekt auch das selbe problem wenn
sie danach stand haben der in einem
gewissen teil der zivilen bevölkerung
rückhalt haupt und kam von der
zivilbevölkerung zu unterscheiden ist ja
also man hört dass sie kennen land und
leute sehr gut woran ist denn aus ihrer
sicht der westen jetzt in den
vergangenen 20 jahren dort gescheitert
warum hat man es eben nicht geschafft
eine gesellschaft dort zu etablieren
die man sich zum ziel gesetzt hatte
das sollte sehr schwierige frage hat
zieht faktoren im endeffekt wurden auch
die pläne haben sich immer gern dort
wurden nicht konsequent durchgeführt ich
denke aber man sollte auch nicht
irgendwie überschätzen dass es am
nächsten gelegen hat oder dass das
andere auto gelegen hat am ende des
tages
ist es praktisch in all diesen kämpfen
vor allem nachdem die internationalen
truppen die kommission beendet rumble
praktisch alle kämpfe waren afghanen
gegen afghanen aufgrund von lokalen
gründen
aufgrund von lokalen gegebenheiten
schlossen sich einige leute der armee
und andere den taliban das ist alles
sehr lokalisiert und im endeffekt es ist
die verantwortung der afghanen die
internationalen streitkräfte haben sich
viele fehler begangen aber dass jetzt
die internationalen streitkräfte alles
verhindern hätten können ist vielleicht
auch eine überschätzung
wie werden mann macht über lokale
begebenheiten ja also mit sicherheit ein
feld das noch aufgearbeitet werden wird
in den nächsten wochen und monaten viele
faktoren die da zusammenkommen vielen
dank franz marty war dass unsere für uns
freier journalist aus der schweiz
dankeschön für diese einschätzungen und
wir werden unseren weg noch mal auf dem
g7-gipfel auch boris johnson der premier
großbritanniens hat daran natürlich
teilgenommen und auch er hat sich danach
geäußert sein statement wollen wir uns
jetzt mal anhören
[Musik]
wie in afghanistan
soweit also das statement von boris
johnson vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
übersetzte er hofft schon und setzt
darauf dass es den g7 möglich sein wird
dank ihres doch relativ großen
einflusses auch in zukunft zumindest die
geschicke afghanistans ein wenig
mitgestalten zu können
wir sprechen mit da ist sie schon nina
niebergall in washington und boris
johnson war auch abhängig davon was die
usa letztlich in dieser frage zu sagen
hatten und präsident biden hat sich
jetzt festgelegt vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz aus deiner sicht in washington
was hat zu dieser entscheidung geführt
was waren seine gründe
ja zunächst einmal muss man sagen dass
joe biden noch nicht persönlich
gesprochen hat es war ein statement
angekündigt schon vor einer stunde er
tritt aber noch nicht vor die presse
bislang haben wir hier in washington nur
aus regierungskreisen gehört das eben an
dieser deadline vom 31 august
festgehalten werden soll jetzt zu deiner
frage nach den gründen
es werden genannt die die sicherheits zu
die sicherheit die sicherheitssituation
in afghanistan gemeint damit ist
vermutlich so hört man hier jetzt auch
schon seit tagen zum einen eben was die
taliban verlauten lassen sie haben ja
gestern eine so ließ es rote linie
gezogen haben darauf gedrängt dass die
usa jetzt wirklich bis zum 31 august aus
dem land abziehen und zum anderen aber
auch auf das wurde hier schon vor
einigen tagen immer wieder gesagt man
hat jetzt auch die befürchtung dass der
islamische staat der ableger des
islamischen staats in afghanistan weiter
tätig werden könnte und im zweifel auch
diese diese diese menschenansammlungen
vor dem flughafen angreifen könnte das
heißt aufgrund dieser
sicherheitsbedenken vor ort heißt es
jetzt soll an dieser deadline
festgehalten werden eine einschränkung
dazu noch auch aus sicherheitskreisen
wie gesagt ein statement darauf warten
wir noch heißt es weiterhin dass beiden
trotzdem das pentagon gebeten haben soll
sich auf eine verlängerung vorzubereiten
also falls es dazu kommen sollte was das
genau heißt das wissen wir es leider
noch nicht
in der tat auch noch eine interessante
wendung die das dann noch mal nehmen
könnte momentan wie gesagt müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass der 31 august die
deadline bleibt dass gerade die sehr
plastischen und konkreten
sicherheitsbedenken der usa erwähnt dies
natürlich jetzt in kabul gibt
insbesondere dort am flughafen oft hat
außenpolitik ja auch stark mit
innenpolitischen erwägungen zu tun wie
sehr stand beiden vielleicht auch unter
druck seiner eigenen partei aber auch
der opposition
er steht hier sehr stark unter druck
tatsächlich wie du sagst aus der eigenen
partei aber auch aus der
republikanischen partei wird sehr scharf
angegriffen schon seit tagen allerdings
haben beide parteien gefordert dass
diese deadline ausgeweitet ausgeweitet
werden soll die republikaner drängen da
sehr stark darauf dass alle us
amerikaner und amerikanerinnen
ausreisen müssen alle die es möchten
viele demokraten gerade von links
verweisen auch immer wieder darauf dass
man auch die afghanen die afghanischen
ortskräfte aus dem land herausholen muss
dass man ihnen die chance geben muss
auch auszureisen und hier in die usa zu
kommen
dh der druck ist groß auch mittlerweile
aus der bevölkerung seine beiden
umfragewerte sind so niedrig wie noch
nie jetzt muss man aber sagen er hat
diesen druck aktuell nicht nachgegeben
als er hält an dieser deadline fest was
es jetzt in den kommenden tagen bedeuten
wird wie vieh er wie diese entscheidung
beurteilt werden wird das wird
sicherlich noch sehr interessant
wird man sehen aber auch klar ein ganz
interessanter aspekt denn also wenn du
es beschreibst da muss man ja sagen okay
er widersetzt sich eigentlich der
öffentlichen meinung und das tun ja
politiker in der regel ungerne was
glaubst du warum macht er das also das
hätte man jetzt donald trump eher
zugetraut als ihn
ja man kann vermuten dass er darauf
hofft dass die amerikaner und
amerikanerinnen ihn am ende nicht daran
messen wird wie er diesen afghanistan
krieg beendet hat also es ist man muss
wissen die us amerikaner und
amerikanerinnen wollen schon seit jahren
dass dieser krieg in afghanistan beendet
wird die sind für den abzug in einer
großen mehrheit und das ist auch nach
wie vor so es ist allerdings auch so
dass es jetzt neue umfragen gibt und die
leute dort gefragt werden was halten sie
denn jetzt davon wie dieser abzug
vonstatten ging und die leute da
natürlich sagen es läuft sehr schlecht
also seine umfragewerte sie sind gerade
nicht besonders gut man ist man könnte
aber vermuten dass eben beiden darauf
spekuliert dass die leute irgendwann
auch diese schlimmen bilder die man im
moment immer noch aus afghanistan sieht
dass sie die na ja vergessen werden
vielleicht nicht aber dass sie zumindest
in den hintergrund rücken werden und es
am ende dann vielleicht doch hängen
bleibt dass viele leute
heroisch mit großen anstrengungen mit
vielen evakuierungs flugzeugen von dort
gerettet werden konnten ob das aber
tatsächlich dann am ende die wahrnehmung
sein wird dass es unklar erscheint aber
darauf zu spekulieren
soweit die einschätzungen von nina
liberale aus washington vielen dank und
wir sprechen bzw haben nochmal vorlieben
ein o-ton der bundespolizei und da geht
es darum welche schwierigkeiten auch
hier in deutschland auftreten für die
geflüchteten die zurückkommen das ist
alles andere als einfach gehören auch da
noch mal rein
heute haben wir fünf bis sechs flüge zu
erwarten aus taschkent also die
regierungsflüge der bundesregierung
kommen in der masse hier in frankfurt am
main an und die bundespolizei macht
jetzt hier die sicherheitsüberprüfungen
die erfassung der leute
wir müssen die idee behandlung machen
die registrierung dabei arbeiten wir
sehr eng mit dem dampf zusammen viele
mitarbeiter vom band sind jetzt auch
hier das ist ein protokoll operation und
dann werden die afghanen die hier
gestrandet sind im prinzip
weitergeleitet aufgeteilt in die
verschiedene bundesländer sind von
ortskräfte frauen kinder männer afghanen
ohne pässe die in diesem chaotischen
umständen hier die flucht gelungen ist
dann müssen wir erst mal gucken wer es
wäre sind aber auch deutsch aufgaben
dabei oder afghanen die in europa und
den usa leben einige wollen und müssen
weiter reisen auch das müssen wir dann
koordinieren dann werden dann flüge
gebucht in andere europäische länder die
auch noch aufgaben aufnehmen wie
zunächst hier gestrandet sind all das
passiert hier und das ist auch eine
große herausforderung
oder sind wir wieder an der stelle noch
mal ein paar user stimmen mit dazu wie
viele millionen ortskräfte sind dennoch
dort fragt uwe lacht man über facebook
und dazu können wir nur sagen es sind
wohl mehrere tausend von millionen war
bislang nicht die rede jörg rau wie kann
man denn die waffen dort lassen absolut
nicht zu verstehen dass seine meinung
josef lang per mail die taliban haben
amnestie zugesagt warum dann diese
panische flucht außerdem besteht dann
kein asylrecht mehr für afghanistan
schreibt er ich lass das jetzt mal so
unkommentiert wir haben noch ein
gespräch vor uns wir sprechen mit einer
jungen frau die es gemeinsam mit ihrem
afghanischen mann aus kabul nach
deutschland geschafft hat wir haben
letzte woche mit ihr gesprochen damals
war sie noch in kabul und sie möchte
unerkannt bleiben aus furcht vor
repressionen die eventuell drohen
könnten vor allem den angehörigen ihres
mannes sie selbst deutsche der mann
afghane vielen dank wir respektieren
natürlich das duo unerkannt bleiben
möchte ist sind trotzdem sehr froh dass
wir mit dir sprechen können letzte woche
hast du noch am flughafen also inmitten
des chaos jetzt in deutschland in
sicherheit wie hat das ganze überhaupt
geklappt
jetzt höre ich ein pfeifton ich hoffe
ihr hört den nicht
hallo
ich habe gerade jeder hört ihnen das ist
unangenehm jetzt ist er weg bei mir
zumindest ich frage nochmal nach den
namen darf ich wie gesagt nicht nennen
wir haben anonymität zugesichert kannst
du mich verstehen
ok alles klar wo dabei ich sag einfach
du das machen wir bei uns in der sendung
so ich heiß christopher gerne auch
zurück dutzend also letzte woche noch am
flughafen inmitten des chaos jetzt in
deutschland in sicherheit wie hat diese
flucht geklappt wo wir jeden tag so
viele leute sehen die es nicht schaffen
wir haben ja
wochen mehrere versucht um auf dem
flughafengelände gelang weiter vergeben
und letztendlich haben wir mit hilfe von
bekannten gegangen
us soldaten kannten dadurch dann haben
wir das flughafengelände geschafft und
konnten dann mit dem deutschen kräften
dann ausgeflogen werden über taschkent
also ihr habt es geschafft andere nicht
wie war das von der welches gefühl war
dass dort zu sein inmitten dieser
szenerie inmitten dieses chaos
einfach furchtbar
wir haben das bisher immer noch nicht
verarbeitet ich glaube das braucht noch
ein bisschen seinerzeit einen
schockzustand
wenn man die situation vor dem geht
trafen praktisch gesehen hat und
miterlebt hat und dann noch mal wenn man
dann direkt auf dem flughafengelände
dann tatsächlich ist sondern da auch das
chaos einfach weiter geht aber irgendwie
eine andere ordnung hat also tagen
menschen familien kindern älterer
menschen auf dem boden geschlafen haben
weil wir wirklich stundenlang tagelang
erst mal aushalten müssen dann
tatsächlich aus fliegen können
menschliches gesagt dass ich kann gehen
tatsächlich die richtigen worte um das
zu beschreiben man das erlebt hat also
auch da natürlich eine immense
enttäuschung und eigentlich entsetzen
über die situation vor ort und
wahrscheinlich auch ich will das jetzt
nicht in den mund legen aber über das
verhalten der bundesregierung oder wie
hast du dich da ja im wahrsten sinne des
wortes abgeholt gefühlt also wie war das
hast du hilfe bekommen hattest du den
eindruck du konntest dich an stellen
wenden hat das irgendwie funktioniert
oder wie würdest du das beschreiben
das was wirklich gut funktioniert war
hat es ist die anmeldung als er das ja
uns auch auf die evakuierungs listen
gesetzt haben dass er das jetzt wirklich
reibungslos
funktioniert alles andere darüber genau
leider gar nicht dass wir haben uns
tatsächlich im stich gelassen gefühlt
dass man letztendlich konnten ihr es ja
auch aus dem land heraus schaffen weil
die us-soldaten uns gehalten haben auf
dauer wirklich tatsächlich keine hilfe
von von deutschland aus dass das was
hier auf kabel raus auf dem
flughafengelände und kein schatten das
uns so so geht es auch vielen anderen us
wir haben wir haben hier eine ortsgruppe
gegründet mit mit ganz vielen anderen
deutschen
[Musik]
ähnlichen situation sind wir damals und
die fühlen sich komplett im stich
gelassen wie gesagt nach wie vor ist der
weg zum flughafen nicht das problem
sondern tatsächlich die man auch auf dem
flughafengelände rhein gelangt das ist
nach wie vor richtig ja lebensbedrohlich
ja aurelia schreibt uns über youtube
kundus kandahar und mazar e sharif da
warten auch noch ortskräfte die kommen
niemals raus jetzt sind wir schön
abhängig von den taliban hattest du
selbst kontakt mit taliban wie haben sie
auf dich gewirkt weil ja auch wie gesagt
immer die frage jetzt im raum steht
haben sie sich vielleicht gemäßigt sind
sie jetzt anders als ich früher
aufgetreten sind wie hast du das erlebt
also ich hab keine bahn erlebt auf dem
weg die klage wo wir auf dem weg immer
zum flughafen waren da habe ich dir
liegt dass hier auch immer wieder das
auto angehalten haben
sobald jemand hat sich mich im auto
gesehen haben haben wir uns einfach
durchgewunken weil eben eine frau im
auto bus und sie niemanden belästigen
wollten
ansonsten habe ich die taliban
ich hab' ich muss auch sagen ich hab
mich auch kaum getraut eigentlich
eigentlich hoch zu schauen als die dann
da waren weil man hat dann einfach angst
gehabt
wir haben viel dafür gesorgt dass
verkehr nicht reibungslos reibungslos
verläuft weil der doch sehr viel los war
ansonsten gab es eine situation am ort
gibt wo tatsächlich ein klar die bahn
gekommen ist und ich meine einfach
in die menge eingeschlagen hat um eins
die menschen weg zu scheuchen
das war für die dialekt oder die
kontaktpunkte in anführungszeichen
na gut das ist natürlich schon
schockierend trotzdem auch nochmal jetzt
die frage auf mit dem blick sozusagen
auf afghanistan jetzt aus der sicherheit
aber dein mann ist afghane hat
angehörige dort wie groß ist auch seine
angst jetzt vor der unmittelbaren
zukunft was befürchtet er was könnte
jetzt auch seinen angehörigen drohen
habt ihr habt ihr sorge habt ihr angst
was was jetzt die nächste zeit handelt
ja wir haben große angst dass auch der
grund warum ich eben unerkannt bleiben
möchte ich hier
meine familie sozusagen haben wir direkt
familienmitglieder die
23 von seiner geschwister die haben
direkt mit deutschen zusammen gearbeitet
das ist unmöglich auch so wie das jetzt
leider auch sieht jetzt zeitlich kaum zu
schaffen ich hoffe das klappt noch
ansonsten haben wir habe ich noch ein
schwager der matura zusammengearbeitet
hat extrem schwierig die menschen daraus
schatten aber auch für seine eltern weil
dann die kinder draußen sind können kann
die älteren menschen für sich alleine ja
nicht so dass die eltern mit der dann
auch mit
rausholen und die würden aber irgendwie
strapaten
sondern von 15 flucht auf sich zu nehmen
wahrscheinlich nicht
ja es wird richtig schwierig das ist wie
wie geht es jetzt bei euch weiter bleibt
also natürlich in kontakt denke ich mit
euren angehörigen aber was ist jetzt
eure hoffnung für die nächste zeit
also die hoffnung ist nicht jetzt noch
innerhalb der nächsten tage jetzt mal
dass sie noch auf einen evakuiert werden
wenn nicht alle hoffnungen natürlich
dass das dann über die vielen flüge also
das hoffentlich ganz normale flugverkehr
dann noch kabul aus wieder starten kann
man weiß es nicht das ist ja alles
ungewiss
dass es dann nicht weiter hoffnung
ansonsten ja ich will alles andere mag
eigentlich gar nicht darüber nachdenken
was ansonsten ist weil das land waren
sich ja dann wie ein gefängnis wegen
gefängnis werden für die man schon waren
es eben diesen weg werden wir nicht gibt
das sind düstere aussichten wir hoffen
natürlich alle dass sie sich so in
dieser form nicht bestätigen werden wir
danken ganz herzlich dafür dass du dir
die zeit genommen hast heute mit uns zu
sprechen auch über dein schicksal und
das deines mannes und da sind natürlich
bei euch und hoffen dass es so gut
ausgeht für euch aber auch für den rest
wie es eben nur möglich ist vielen dank
für das gespräch und ich nehme
vielleicht gerade noch mal an dieser
stelle heute über youtube rein 14 heißt
14 euro glaube man hat sich da auch
eingeredet man könne afghanistan
demokratie bringen wenn man die menschen
nicht davon überzeugt so ist das auch
nicht nachhaltig damit hat er leider
wohl recht wir danken euch an dieser
stelle für die zuschriften für die
fragen und die kommentare und wünschen
euch noch einen schönen abend das thema
afghanistan wird uns noch eine ganze
weile beschäftigen danke für heute und
auf wiedersehen